Voiceover:Let's think about what it means
to add numbers.
So let's start with 1.
1 plus.
1 plus 1.
What is this going to be equal to?
One way to think about this is we have
1 thing, and that thing
will be a purple circle.
So let me put that here.
So that's this 1 thing.
I'm just going to represent it with
a purple circle.
And I'm going to add another 1 thing.
And since this is in blue, I'll make
that other circle, I'll
make that in blue as well.
So let me put that right over here.
So 1 plus 1.
1 plus 1.
How many total circles do I now have?
Well, I now have 2 circles.
I now have 2 circles.
1 plus 1 is equal to, is equal to 2.
Okay, you're saying all
right Sal, all right,
that makes sense.
Let's do this with larger numbers.
So let's say we want
to know what equals ...
And I'll put a question mark over here.
So, question mark.
What equals ...
So something is equal to, is equal to,
let's say, 2, 2, 2 plus 3.
Something is equal to 2 plus 3.
What is this something going to be?
I encourage you to pause
the video and think
about it on your own.
Well, you could view
this as, I have 2 objects
and then we're going to
add another 3 objects.
How many total objects would I have?
So you have your 2 objects, which I'll use
purple circles again.
So let me ...
Let me, so, we have 1
and 2 purple circles.
This is the 2 right over here.
And then to that we're
going to add 3 more.
3 more circles.
I'll represent those in blue because we
wrote the 3, here, in blue.
So that is 1, 2, and 3.
So how many total circles do we now have?
Well, we could count them.
We have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
In fact, let me count that.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 circles.
So 2 plus 3.
2 things plus another
3 things are 5 things.
So our question mark, right over here,
is equal to 5.
So instead of writing the question mark
right over here, let me clear that out.
I could say 5 is equal to.
I could write down that
5 is equal to 2 plus 3.